the upside to the pandemic is in the air
it's cleaner there's less pollution
because we're flying less
driving less and industry has slowed to
almost a halt
greenhouse gas emissions plunged in
april by about 17
overall in some countries the drop was
more like 40 percent
that is great news and it feels like
nature
is rebalancing a bit though as jeff
semple explains it's just a blip in the
big picture of climate change
paul koch woke up one morning last month
to find a trespasser
taking a dip so i called my wife and
said there's a moose in the pool the 800
pounder made quite a splash
for several hours before making her own
way out of the backyard
coke and his wife have lived in this
suburban ottawa neighborhood for 40
years
but this was a first we've had lots of
pool parties over the years but not one
with a moose
or any animal with humans living in
lockdown the animal kingdom
is reclaiming some territory
in thailand these monkeys are going ape
embroiled in a street fight
over food in the center of town
wild turkeys are strolling the suburbs
of louisiana
even penguins have been spotted
jaywalking in south africa
the list of unusual wildlife sightings
goes on and on
and on this cartoon pretty much sums up
the sentiment even here on the campus
the university of toronto scarborough
when i bike in i routinely see deer now
in campus
the major inhibitor of the movement of
animals across the city is traffic
will be busy roads and now we've seen
major roads made arteries in the city
being almost devoid of cars this spring
traffic volumes in toronto were cut
in half and those silent streets are
also providing a breath
of fresh air smoggy skylines from some
of the world's most polluted places
are clearing the contrast is even
starker from space
revealing nitrogen dioxide emissions in
china and italy
before and after the lockdown in india
particle pollution fell by nearly 60
percent
we are seeing improvements here in north
america as well during the pandemics
peak
canada's largest city saw air pollution
levels highlighted
here in blue drop by 15 percent
i would suspect that we could probably
see a 40-50 percent reduction
in the number of smoggy days pollution
kills 7
million people every year according to
the world health organization
and some experts expect that this
cleaner air
might actually save more lives this year
than are lost to the virus
and that plummeting pollution is also
sparking a debate
over whether the pandemic might be
flattening the climate curve
2020 is witnessing a carbon crash
co2 emissions which fuel climate change
are taking a nosedive unlike anything
we've seen before
the reduction in in terms of tons of co2
which is what really matters for the
atmosphere
we're definitely going to have by far
the biggest reduction ever
the good news even as economies reopen
carbon emissions are expected to end the
year
down around 8 the equivalent of india's
entire
energy use which brings us to the bad
news
even if we get an 8 reduction this year
that's that's the sort of
magnitude of reduction we would need
this year
next year the year after and every
single year
in order to limit warming to 1.5 degrees
to meet the paris summit goal and
prevent the worst of climate change
global emissions need to fall by 7.6
every year for a decade even this
unprecedented lockdown
amounts to little more than a first step
basically we need this kind of reduction
every year
and we don't want to have a pandemic to
do that we don't want to have an
economic recession
to do that and so we're going to need to
make relatively large changes
and some believe this moment represents
our best chance for that change
a golden opportunity to go green
we all get up every morning we get into
our cars we drive we
go to meetings all over the world and
everywhere all the time
and now we've learned hello i think we
can do these things a lot better
jatin nathwani's office offers a glimpse
into a sustainable future
a zero-carbon building one of canada's
first with a solar paneled roof and
geothermal heating
the university of waterloo professor
believes this economic crisis
offers a chance to invest in these
technologies
he points to the last time carbon
emissions dropped following the global
recession in 2009
governments then responded by pumping
billions into stimulus projects
construction designed to boost the
economy but that also saw a sharp spike
in emissions
there wasn't anything green about it
because there's typically not much green
about
you know expanding a road or building a
bridge or putting a new
roof on the community ring but this time
around
many countries are eyeing a so-called
green
recovery the european union is making
climate change the centerpiece of its
trillion dollar investment
a stimulus package steering away from
fossil fuels and towards
energy efficient projects france is
offering financial aid to beleaguered
airlines but only in exchange for
investments
in lower emission aircraft even china
the world's largest emitter has endorsed
big spending on a slew of low-carbon
infrastructure
albeit while still building new coal
plants
i believe that this is going to be
different and
will be different partly because the
recognition
the notion that we are really facing
a very severe climate question is no
longer a matter of debate
the united states may prove the
exception as the white house steadily
slashes green protections
but what about canada so far the federal
government has pledged 1.7 billion to
clean up
orphaned and abandoned oil and gas wells
in alberta saskatchewan and bc
salvaging thousands of jobs if we can
put some of the people who were
displaced out of the oil patch back to
work
into the cleanup process then that
actually
is you know is helping in that labor
market canada's oil sector was already
reeling before the pandemic pushed gas
prices down
another 20 percent analysts predict
demand for oil
may take years to fully recover i think
we're seeing a
transformation here that is quite
fundamental that decouples our
dependence on
oil and fossil fuels he argues this
pandemic presents an opportunity to fast
track the transition to renewable energy
we should aim for an orderly phase an
orderly transition
to efficiency electric vehicles
rather than trying to prop up and
maintain an industry that has no
long-term future
the government is being offered an
opportunity
on a golden plat platter but i'm not too
confident that they will take that
opportunity political will to push
drastic change can be hard to come by in
normal times
but this is anything but the pandemic
has seen
millions heed the advice of experts to
protect
against an invisible threat the canadian
public has listened
we've stayed home we physically
distanced
we are listening to medical experts and
their advice
to keep us safe now we need to do the
same thing
when it comes to climate change to
protect the future not only for
ourselves
but also our furry friends